[Musique]
bienvenue dans l'essentiel le magazine
qui reprend toute l'actualité de la
semaine au département
[Musique]
l'essentiel de cette semaine est
consacrée au pacte de solidarité
territoriale
le département a initié cette année ce
nouveau dispositif dead et
d'accompagnement en faveur des communes
une convention qui prévoit une enveloppe
budgétaire d'un montant de 90 millions
d'euros disponible pour une période de
trois ans le 13 juin dernier st pierre a
été la première commune a signé le pacte
de solidarité territoriale avec le
département et cilaos et saint-andré ont
également pris part à cette convention
le 25 juillet dernier c'est la commune
du port qui signe son pst une aide
départementale à hauteur de 3 millions
d'euros en investissement et de 500000
euros en fonctionnement et mise à
disposition
avec ces fonds financeront pour exemple
un projet d'accessibilité numérique en
faveur des personnes âgées
ce pacte de solidarité signifie qu'on va
pouvoir figer une enveloppe à la fin d'
investissement et en fonctionnement
parce que c'est important aujourd'hui de
contractualiser entre collectivités
compte tenu de la situation nationale où
le gouvernement est en train de
ratiboiser sur la hache en train de
ratiboiser sur l'accession à la
propriété
donc voilà là où on doit mettre l'accent
on doit mettre la priorité c'est ce
qu'on fait et c'est ce qu'on a fait avec
ce pacte de solidarité
bras panon et la cinquième commune de
lille a signé son pacte de solidarité
territoriale soit 2,4 millions d'euros
des dents fonctionnement et 600000 euros
en budget de fonctionnement
on va surtout aller sur l'accompagnement
portage de repas à domicile nous allons
pour continuer à en faire un peu plus
nous faisons sans portage de repas à
domicile sur feront de 200 portage de
repas à domicile
pareil le ce fonctionnement permettra de
financer la la sécurité des personnes
âgées dans le cadre d'un partenariat
avec des opérateurs qui aujourd'hui sont
sur la télésurveillance de personnages
et nous prendrons en charge avec le
département 50 % de la valeur du service
dont ces personnes âgées urnes ont
besoin de l'école primaire ma pensée à
bras panon est un établissement
précurseur ici les élèves sont dotés
d'outils numériques pour suivre les
enseignements tablettes et tableaux
connectés sont désormais les nouveaux
supports éducatifs l'établissement grâce
au pst ouvrira deux classes inclusive
qui accueilleront une vingtaine
d'enfants autistes ou avec des troubles
du comportement
donc ce sont des classes qui vont être
équipés adapté neuf qu'ils vont être
livrés pour la fin au même pas fan cette
année début de l'année prochaine et qui
a une valeur de 300 millions
salazie signe également son pst avec le
département une commune isolée qui
bénéficient d'une aide de 2 millions 400
mille euros pour son développement et
son désenclavement
nous sommes à l'ère du numérique tout va
très vite maintenant qui est important
que les amendes que nos écoles soient
équipés de tablettes et que locution
avec nos enfants travailler sur cette
ère du numérique qu'ils puissent avoir
ainsi d'un désenclavement le service
l'asie est un endroit enclavé est
important que nous puissions avoir un
désenclavement de siège de salage des
mais c'est aussi d'autres projets sur
l'eau potable c'est des projets sur
l'amélioration des routes et des et les
chemins de salazie tout ça pour gagner
de la population pour son développement
des projets de développement qu'il soit
en investissements sur le territoire ou
en fonctionnement dans le domaine social
sont soutenus dans le cadre du pst
un dispositif que le département
souhaite rapidement étendre à l'ensemble
des communes de ville parce que il ya
une forme d'urgence sociale les mesures
sociales doivent être mobilisés
rapidement
nous voulons renforcer le lien social
nous voulons renforcer aussi les mesures
en termes d'équipements de proximité
c'est pour cela que je ne veux pas tant
des jeux passe
comme une approche commune je rencontre
les maires les équipes municipales pour
aller signer et mobiliser les crédits
moi j'ai envie qu'on aille vite parce
que la population exige il y a des
attentes faute et ces attentes doivent
d'être bien sûr satisfaites
à travers ces packs de solidarité je
suis content je remercie les élus les
services administratifs qui nous
accompagnent ce dossier le bonus de
cette semaine est consacré aux vacances
partez à la découverte des équipements
culturels du département
[Musique]
coût
l'essentiel de cette semaine est
consacrée au pacte de solidarité
territoriale
l'essentiel de cette semaine est
consacré l'essentiel de ses
bras panon et la cinquième commune de
lille a signé le pacte de solidarité
territoriale soit 2,4 soit 2.4 millions
d'euros dead en investissement et 600000
euros en budget de fonctionnement
l'établissement grâce au pst ouvrir à
l'établissement grâce au pst ouvrira
deux classes inclusive qui accueilleront
une vingtaine d'enfants autistes ou avec
des taux
salazie signe également son pst avec le
département une commune isolée qui
bénéfient 1
les projets de développement qu'il soit
en investissements sur le territoire ou
en fonctionnement dans le domaine social
sont soutenus dans le cadre du pst un
dispositif que le département souhaite
rapidement étendre à l'ensemble des
communes de l'île les projets de
développement les projets de
développement qu'il soit